I'm Emily I'm Joyce I'm teddy I'm mirre
and today we're gonna be trying for
different spicy chicken sandwiches from
four different fast food restaurants I'm
gonna try to figure out where they're
from I've had it every single one of
these sandwiches at least once in my
life I love spicy chicken sandwiches but
my butthole doesn't i love me the core
of my being just loves me in all that
spicy let's get it armed okay let's
start with this guy over here
she's shiny she's shiny so much mail
this is definitely oh my god good hit it
does have a good pic I don't I don't
notice any place that's why you it's
supposed to me honestly
but it ain't it's like when my white
friends tell me hot cheetos are hot so
like whether these would add tomatoes to
the sacred highway just like yeah right
okay since we're 50/50 on the Wendy's
Burger King I'm gonna say Burger King
and that way if one of us wins actually
number two he's probably from mm-hm
he looks like he might be from Kentucky
okay but not too much there's all that
spicy though but had like there's a
lemony flavor
it could be Burger King it has an
aftertaste of a Burger King all right
number three all right this look like
chick-fil-a it no no no Who am I I don't
know
[Music]
now you're making me want to say this is
Burger King and that's Wendy's Burger
King Wendy's Burger King Wendy's Burger
King Wendy's which means baby daddy okay
you ready yeah of course you know our
pickling chicken oh I was gonna hold on
to this one my mom made it is from [ __ ]
she's like when yo ass down to the
kitchen our chicken no filler this is a
little spicy and I'm into it
like yeah retweet first of all Wendy's
Wendy's can't see tipsy
[Music]
[Applause]
a lounge at the Dane Cook joke
chick-fil-a chick-fil-a four out of four
packs like one so if anybody ever wants
to come up again they could fight us cuz
we know where our chicken is from we
know her name we know her taste oh yes
if you guys want issues you can bring
tissues can I can I finish my
chick-fil-a now
[Music]